uh all right we mentioned the eagles we
mentioned carson wentz we mentioned
jalen hurts how about jalen hurts from
yesterday talking about the reality that
nick ciriano the coach of the eagles
refuses to hand any starting jobs to any
of the players including jalen hurts
here's hertz
no one is above that
um and everybody
every everybody got to go to work you
know so for me
i know rent renters do every day it's
always been that way for me always been
a get better mentality every day grow
every day uh be a better leader every
day be a better quarterback every day
and when that rents due i don't plan on
missing no payments so
it's work
yeah i look i i pete oversold the
comments frankly i
okay what else is he gonna say chris
what else is he gonna say he he
he can't he goes i'm the starter and i'm
offended that i have to compete for this
job he said what he was going to say no
that's all he can say i know it is all i
could say he continues the one thing
i'll say about it though is
he he continues to say and handle
himself the right way
like that that's the thing that i'm
impressed with with jalen hurts you know
he's got some very mature sayings like i
i heard a few last year that jumped out
to me and i was like this guy gets it
like that right there i just love that
it's a great message to send to your
team rents due every day i'm here i'm
going to pay it thanks for having me
thanks for paying a paycheck i'm going
to work hard i'm going to get better you
know that's those are the things you
want to hear from your quarterback
you're right you don't you can't say
much different but i do think the way he
packages his messages are
show his charisma and leader leadership
that way but he is going to have to earn
it certainly and nick cirianni's never
really had a quarterback
like him so this is going to be
different for him too so maybe that's
why he has a little trepidation as far
as just naming the starter he's got more
experience with a guy like joe flacco
than he has a jalen hurts you know oh
what old aging you know pocket
quarterback aka phillip rivers who
siriani has been with for what he was
with with three out of the last five
years four to the last six years
something like that so uh yeah siriani
of course is not going to anoint anyone
jalen hurts hasn't done anything to be
anointed that guy quite yet and he
realizes that and i respect him for that
at least the way he handles himself in
these situations
yeah i don't disagree with you there and
i think he's smart enough to realize
that
even if he wins the starting job and
there's no reason to think that he won't
all due respect to joe flacco this is
set up for hertz to be the guy this year
and to prove what he can do this year
and to do enough this year to earn next
year with the asterisk the caveat
the
keep your eye on desean watson
possibility because if watson's in play
i think the eagles are going to make a
move for him and why wouldn't they
because with jalen hurts they have a guy
who could become if everything works out
perfectly what deshaun watson is
if you can get to sean watson you don't
have to hope that someone else can maybe
if everything goes just right become
something close to deshaun watson so uh
you know and i think hertz is smart
enough to realize that too chris i do
too i do i mean they're they're they're
a team in rebuild transition whatever
you want to say
uh i i yes
i do like you said earlier this in this
show if watson becomes available i do
believe they're going to be a team
that's very interested in and in the
market for him there's no doubt jalen
hurts is interesting you're right he
could maybe be a desean watson or
anything like that i don't know but
there's got to be a lot there's got to
be growth growth in the past game as a
passer in general he's a really good
athlete we saw the ability to make some
great throws and some eye popping throws
i mean geez i think about that dallas
cowboy i think it was the post ratty
thought through to desean jackson like
hey listen that shows you some of the
capabilities he has but there's there's
10 or 12 throws i could also show you
from that game to go damn that's not
starting caliber type of play or
throwing yet and that's where he's going
to get cleaned up he's just got to
become a machine throwing the football
because eventually
teams will figure out how to defend them
with him at quarterback and running the
ball and doing those things to where
he's going to have to back some people
off with his right arm and his pocket
passing and that's really going to
dictate how his career goes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports